all right we've got to get to something
really really important this needs to be
i am going to show you a video that
justifies
launching a new investigation into
republican congressman
jim jordan and whether he was an
accomplice in a greater way than we
already knew
to the january 6th riots think back
a week to when nancy pelosi said
jim jordan and jim banks can't be on
this committee
investigating the january 6th riots
and at the time i said jim jordan is
more likely a witness
or a co-conspirator than he can really
in any realistic way
be an investigator of what took place on
january 6th
he appeared yesterday on fox news with
bret baier
and bret bayer asked him did you speak
to trump on january 6th
and jim jordan is caught obviously
trying to obfuscate
you've got to see this let's listen to
it line by line
okay here we go he's obviously going to
go down a number of different roads
uh about who knew what when who was
talking to coordinators of the protest
did you talk to the former president
that day i've talked to the former
president umpteen times thousands
i mean i may not that okay did you talk
to the president on january 6th
and uh jordan says i've talked to the
president umpteen
times and bret baier tries to clarify
exactly the date on which he's referring
to
the former president umpteen times
thousands i mean i may not have i mean
countless countless times i talk to the
president i never talk about what we
talk about
okay so he's still now he says i talked
to the president
he's still not saying on that day but it
seems to be what he's conceding here
that's appropriate just like i don't
talk about what happens in republican
conferences so i've talked to the
president
numerous times uh i continue to talk to
the president
on january 6 congressman yes i mean i've
talked to the president
i've talked to the president so many i
can't remember so he seems to be
realizing
he can't just lie and say no and he
seems to be realizing
bret bayer is going to keep asking the
question so he tries to slide it in and
says
yes meaning yes i did speak to trump on
january 6 but i've talked to him so many
times
i can't even remember all the times i've
talked to him remember all the days i've
talked to him but i've certainly talked
to the president yeah
and and on that day was
can you share any of the insight of what
he was thinking about that day
very clear question what's the relevance
the relevance is
i alone can fix it the book from carol
lennon philip rucker
says it has multiple sources who say
trump was basically giddy on january 6th
the reason trump didn't send in the
national guard is he loved what was
going on he was giddy
he was absolutely loving it and my guess
is that when jim jordan spoke to trump
trump expressed being thrilled about
what was going on now what jim jordan
said we don't know
but it's obvious why jim jordan doesn't
want to talk about what that
conversation was like
uh brett the people we need to come
testify are the people who can testify
to
the fundamental questions well one of
those people might be jim jordan
what exactly was trump's mental state
when you spoke to him was he giddy
about the riots why didn't the united
states capital the people's house have
an appropriate
security posture on that day and what
have we done those are the people we
need to hear from
those that's the information and
testimony we need to get
that's what we should focus on but i
don't think that benny thompson the
chairman of this committee said
the question wasn't about benny thompson
you know the question was about
your conversation with trump things on
the table until we raise this issue
about
the speaker's office is the one who
knows what what the security posture and
why it was
the way it was once we raised that
question said well everything's on the
table
okay so he clearly doesn't want to talk
about what he said to donald trump now
what do we know about jim jordan well
we know that uh jim jordan was part of a
meeting
of house republicans that took place in
advance of january 6
about how to overturn the election we
know jim jordan was there
it's been widely reported we are aware
that on december
21st of 2020 marjorie taylor greene
matt gates jim jordan mo brooks and
louis gomer
really a cast of characters were spotted
at the white house and the reports are
that they met with donald trump so
we know jim jordan met with trump about
how to overturn the results in advance
of january 6.
we know that jim jordan voted against
certifying the results
and we now know that jim jordan through
his obfuscation and his distraction
we know that jim jordan also spoke to
donald trump on january 6. we also know
that trump was reportedly giddy on
january 6th about the riots
we also uh know that donald trump was
responsible
for the military not getting to the
capitol
as quickly as they could have on january
6th and here
is the slow drip about the truth of
jordan's potential role on january
6th my guess is that jordan's
fingerprints
are all over the january 6th riots i'm
sure there was lots of locker room talk
about it and the idea i mean imagine
jim jordan tried to argue his way into
being
an investigator of the january 6th riots
good for nancy pelosi for saying you
can't be on the panel
jim and the reality as we now know it
is that this guy is almost certainly
a witness to the inciting of that
in his conversation with donald trump
and he may even
be an accomplice in what took place on
january 6th
unbelievable truly unbelievable